over the past twelve months I have taken
note of any and all notable figures who
have seen their careers fall apart this
year saw more than a few high-profile
careers completely collapse I suppose
when choosing the career crashes we try
to look for individuals who've seen
their professional reputations taken
significant hits in the past year so
their careers start necessarily have to
be over but they should have been pretty
tarnished from actresses to athletes
entrepreneurs to executives I've kept a
list of about three dozen or so names
and in the end we whittled it down to
the 13 biggest crashes of all 2019 was a
record-breaking year for CEO turn over a
thousand CEOs left their positions this
year so it shouldn't come as a surprise
that seven made our list of 13 among the
CEOs that we have on our list this year
our Kevin Burns former CEO of Jul Steve
Easterbrook former CEO of McDonalds and
geisha Williams former CEO of PG&E so
geisha Williams stepped away from her
job 22 months after rising to the helm
of the California Power Company her
departure came as the California Power
Company was facing billions and
potential liabilities for its roles in
at least 17 California wildfires since
2017 Williams stepping away from her
role was both a loss for PG&E and
corporate America as she was the only
latina CEO of any large cap company
allegations of sexual misconduct brought
down four of the individuals on this
year's list but none made news quite
like our Kelly after decades of
allegations of alleged abuse lifetimes
premiering surviving our Kelly placed
his misconduct under an inescapable
spotlight since then he's been charged
with 42 crimes and has pled not guilty
to all other famous faces on this list
include Michael avenatti Felicity
Huffman and Lori Loughlin in March both
actresses were charged by federal
prosecutors for their involvement in
operation varsity blues which is the
largest college admissions scam ever to
be prosecuted by the Department of
Justice in the end no one on this list
felt quite like Adam Newman
filing to go public marked the beginning
of the end for the wework co-founder and
CEO the co-working company's s-1 filing
revealed among other things billions and
losses dating back to 2016 it also
revealed that Newman had trademarked and
sold
his own company the rights to the word
we for 5.9 million dollars within six
weeks the embattled entrepreneur was out
there reporting for career crashes is a
really long process it involves
constantly keeping my finger on the
pulse of what's going on in the news
throughout the course of the year and
remembering that anyone can have their
career crash not just executives at the
end of the reporting process they always
think oh we don't have that many this
year and then I'm always surprised by
how many in fact we have on our list
I suppose anyone can redeem themselves
but I will say that in the past those
who have appeared on our list either
have seen their careers continue to stay
down or they even reappeared on our list
further down the line
[Music]